gonna have your attention please
everyone put your hands up
and no one gets hurt now one of you will
send me all your users data and credit
card information right now phew start
working and no one gets hurt
I actually don't know how
you do work here right yeah I I do I do
but I've never worked on this code base
before because it's not my job so I
don't know
um he does
give me the data I'm not playing around
okay okay
oh no no no I I just need two Factor
authentication to remotely access our
servers you lie to me
and I blow it right now
God damn what is taking so long I'm
sorry so sometimes it takes a while to
receive the text
let me try again
oh yeah I received both of them
all right I I sent it
I don't see it
I'm [ __ ] around where the [ __ ] is my
data
I did send them
I sent this live message to my manager
okay to request read access to the
database you don't have read access well
I haven't worked on it in a while so I
lost my privileges
oh okay I got it
oh shoot oh
I forgot uh what I'm so sorry but for me
to get it I need to
buy a ticket to I.T I.T
are you kidding me
even I know that'll take weeks I'm so
I'm sorry I have a family and my Equity
hasn't fully vested yet
all right [ __ ] it where do you guys
store your snacks uh that's a micro
kitchen
over there
I'm not gonna leave this place
empty-handed
holy [ __ ]
I put this on my performance review
thanks so much for watching that always
appreciate that now if you're
interviewing I actually have this
platform that I really like that I trust
the platform is called exponent they
teach interview prep for everything and
what they do is they have courses that
you could learn how to pass the
interview and they also have specific
guides like for example this one's a
specific Google guide
and then they also have an interview
Bank created by the community and they
have coaching which is great and finally
they also have referrals and with the
referrals you can get the interviews a
lot easier so if you're interested in
that click the link down below I trust
that they'll help you pass your
interview so just check them out see ya